call of duty black ops cold war is set
between black ops 1 and 2.
it's a sequel to the original not a
reboot like last year's modern warfare
and given that it's been 10 years since
black ops
i'll bet you forgot a bunch of what
happened in that game
this video is going to update a previous
story breakdown we did and give you
new information to get you ready for
black ops cold war
are you serious right now don't get them
started
hold on let me set the record straight
here we go
the main story of black ops when you
reduce all the noise and flashing
numbers
the plot of call of duty black ops 1 is
pretty straightforward
it's a story about a man undergoing two
competing brainwashing programs
one to work for russia and kill an
american president
and the counter programming to kill the
russian military leaders responsible for
the brainwashing in the first place
the entire rest of the story is just
about who he does and doesn't kill
[Music]
revenge mason now
the players alex mason a cia officer
is captured in cuba after a failed
attempt on the life of fidel castro
during the bay of pigs the bay of pigs
was a real-life botched operation to
train cuban exiles
and land them back in cuba to overthrow
castro black ops build off of the
military disaster that ensued and in its
story
castro sets up a trap to capture
high-level americans
who could get close to key american
leaders mason is taken and sent to a
russian labor camp called vorkuta
in order to be made into a sleeper agent
through an experimental brainwashing
program
run by russian major general nikita
dragovich dragovich's plan is to send
sleeper agents back to the united states
and trigger them at the right time to do
very bad things like
kill the president the pre-programmed
trigger is to be broadcast off of a ship
called rusalka
through a series of mysterious numbers
mason we want the numbers mason that's
all we've ever wanted
mason ends up being very resistant to
the brainwashing program
and at one point is given up as a
failure that's when victor reznoff
who fought for russia during world war
ii and was betrayed by dragovich
makes his move he messes with mason's
programming and
sends him to kill his own rivals
drakovic
trashcenko and steiner all must die
by the end of black ops 1 reznov seems
to have come out on top
sort of mason kills both the nazi
scientists steiner
and the russian commander dragovich but
it is heavily implied although not
confirmed
that he may have also been involved in
killing president john f
kennedy which was his original
programming it's also very
likely that victor reznov never actually
made it out of the labor camp for kuta
and he died at this moment in the story
and only lives on in mason's head
i guess that's one way of not having to
pay for gary oldman to come back
what you need to know for black ops cold
war black ops cold war mostly takes
place around 1981 but has
multiple flashbacks one of those will be
set in 1968
during the vietnam war the year that
black ops won ended with some
cliffhangers so what happened in 1968
for starters frank woods a main
character who you fight alongside in
black ops 1
is presumed dead after saving your life
we know from later black ops games that
he was actually captured and
sent to the infamous torture prison
known as the hanoi hilton
we have never seen how he managed to
escape but we do know he was then moved
to da nang as a prisoner of war until at
least
1972. given woods is a central character
in cold war we're looking forward to
either finding intel
or hearing some salty jokes from him on
what really happened
we're just should be
concerned alex mason who is also in cold
war is still affected by the numbers
program
and continues to rely on woods to be his
quote
anchor to reality the end of black ops 1
plainly states the numbers program had
much more to it than just a nova 6
chemical weapons plot
and there are more sleeper agents
perseus knows about vorkuta and is
definitely interested in these agents
expect to find some more information and
references to mason's brainwashing and
the numbers program
crossbow
kravchenko who was on the list of people
mason was supposed to kill
is also still alive previously you've
only encountered him in active war zones
but now you'll get a chance to see what
he's like in an office setting
when he's not physically trying to stomp
your face in he's definitely not going
to die however because that happens
later in the series that doesn't sound
too
soviet of you brother what we know about
cold war's plot
the main part of cold war takes place in
1981 which is 13 years after black ops 1
and the failure of the numbers program
but the soviet union hasn't given up
plotting to bring down america
and have infiltrated america's nuclear
programs however
cold war does not take place in america
and is almost entirely focused on cold
war europe as an alliance of
international spy agencies work to
thwart a new plot from russia
although mason woods and jason hudson
are in cold war
a cast of new characters are also
hunting perseus
including a cia officer named russell
adler lead writer murray kraft said that
players are supposed to question his
intentions and we know the game has
multiple endings so keep an eye on that
guy
expect to encounter him in the 1980s and
in a number of flashbacks
to learn what he was up to the other new
characters are eleazar or lazar from the
israel defense forces
helen park from mi6 and lawrence sims a
cia officer who was also in
the vietnam war you'll get to know these
characters not only through missions but
through talking to them
at the safe house the safe house also
seems to contain a lot of intel on black
ops 1
with files on deceased villain dragovich
references to the numbers program
snippets about the kennedy assassination
that mason may or may not have done
and other puzzles a lot of this comes
from collecting intel
during missions this may mean stopping
in the middle of a firefight to take
pictures or pick up files
make sure to fully explore the safe
house and solve its puzzles
some of the things you do in the
safehouse as well as optional objectives
in missions and the two optional side
missions
on the evidence board will impact the
ending some of those items
have really big impacts we're not going
to tell you which ones or how they
change things
so don't worry missing in our
playthrough was joseph bowman's kid
william bowman who was the hacker that
took players through an alternate
reality game
called pawn takes pawn leading up to the
launch of cold war
he doesn't seem to be in the actual game
or at least
not yet so what loose ends from black
ops 1 would you like to see come up in
cold war
let us know in the comments below and if
you want to know more about cold war
we've got a review
gameplay and many more features coming
your way so thanks for watching
[Music]
you